pero no hay que olvidar que nuestros
juegos olímpicos de invierno también hay
latinoamericanos le preguntó entonces
cómo fue la actuación de nuestros
atletas latinoamericanos 10 países y
territorios latinoamericanos tenemos en
estas justas y vamos a tener un mexicano
en la final del patinaje individual es
donovan carrillo el primer patinador de
su país en llegar a una cita olímpica en
30 años no no mantiene de 22 años
completo hoy el programa acordó y
terminó en la decimonovena posición lo
que le permite su pase al programa libre
a la final puntuación de 79 69 para él
nacido en guadalajara quien consigue si
su récord personal superando el 73 91
que consiguió en el mundial de estocolmo
del año pasado no nomás sigue su camino
pero los que no pudieron avanzar son el
argentino franco del farra eliminado en
el sprint de estilo libre de esquí de
fondo tampoco lo hizo su compatriota
náyera díaz gonzález en esta misma
prueba cayeron también el chileno
jonathan fernández y el colombiano
carlos quintana raúl volviendo a donar a
donovan te voy a contar porque él
comenzó a patinar tenía ocho años y
acompañaba a su hermana patinaje y se
enamoró de una chica y para conquistarla
él empezó a patinar cuenta que
terminaron compartiendo pse de cartas de
amor y dándose la mano y fue así como
encontró dos amores esta chica y el amor
por el patinaje un amor que calienta el
hielo y me salió muestras
romántica horribles